at Worlds and a young woman clutches an
egg fully devoted to protecting
whatever's inside the lass
she's approached by a warrior who
crushes the egg shattering all of the
illusions that it represented I could
just as easily be talking about Dark
Souls 3 with that statement
fact is Miyazaki has a long-standing
tradition of pulling quite heavily from
other forms of media and just like
learning about Artorias from guts just
like learning about blood-borne
from HP Lovecraft I want Angel's egg to
teach us about Fillion or and I will
answer the following questions one what
does the egg represent and to pound to
spill Ian or have the power to forestall
the end of the world and making a
mistake that's exactly what she's doing
these questions aren't really touched
upon in a game at all not in any
descriptions and you'd think that they
would be but Angel's egg this animated
movie made by Mamoru Oshii in 1985
succinctly answers both of these
questions and the answer is faith a
young girl wonders an abandoned city
filling glass arms with water she knows
not why she does this yet she does it
all the same and in much the same way
she carries and protect this large egg
holding it closely throughout the movie
and long story short you should watch
the movie if you're interested one of
the very few pieces of dialogue in this
movie talks about a bird that represents
life outside of this world and the girl
believes that the bird now resides
inside of the egg
so no come on a national holiday mean
again so no noggin running on La Coruna
this character the warrior wishes to
break the egg and know one way or
another what's inside but the girl
believes it will hatch and the point I
want to make is this blind faith offers
this great deal of power because
believing something will hatch from the
egg many would say is better than
knowing one way or another for there may
well be nothing inside the egg or
whatever's inside might have already
died so compared to the grim skeptical
warrior the girl is comforted by her
faith and she moves with purpose she's
protected by faith non-evil Suribachi me
no Munna no dad
Louis Vuitton cousin ordered the end
result of analyzing Angels egg in this
way is that we can now reliably ascribe
faith to Fillion ores character and
that's very important because in Dark
Souls faith has a remarkable amount of
power I mean think about it when you
learn a miracle in this game what you're
actually doing from a lore perspective
is learning how to recite the words of a
famous miracle the mere act of which can
heal wounds emit force cast lightning
many other things miracles began as
tales told by gods passed down through
us since the first flame isn't it
extraordinary to think they've existed
since the very origins of the world
furthermore true faith is blind that
much is obvious and it's at the very
core of faith but in Dark Souls 3 it
takes that a little bit further because
not only do miracles require faith it
just so happens that being blind
enhances their power
remember all tones in Dark Souls 3 are
actually in Braille which is a language
of physical bumps for the blind to be
able to read a practice in Dark Souls 3
that is informed from the tradition of
placing and I quote great faith in the
words of the blind so not only is
Fillion or a blind woman of faith she's
also the daughter of Gwyn and she
doesn't need to recite no simple miracle
it's likely that she is the miracle this
legendary character a direct descendant
of what could only be called a God is
something you tell tales about so she
has power we know that much but
is this power being put towards I think
there is only really one possible answer
which is this Fillion or prevents time
from passing we know this because
disturbing her doesn't just dispel a
simple illusion it actually brings us
forward in time to the ring city which
has fallen to ash to Gayle with his
rusted and broken weapons in hand to the
pygmy Lords the blood of the Dark Soul
dried in their veins and back to Fillion
or dead and withered perhaps at the
moment where her faith or her power
finally gave out so we've done our best
to establish the power by which Fillion
all holds back time but what is she
manipulating what does she have control
over with this power well it's possible
that she's manipulating light because
light equals time according to the
repair sorcery which assumedly uses
light to reverse time upon your weapons
the foundations of this spell are a well
guarded secret for light is time and the
reversal of its effects is a forbidden
art if fillion all is indeed
manipulating light to keep the ring city
locked in time and you can kind of
understand why this magic would be both
forbidden and a well guarded secret the
gods would not want this power nor this
secret being used elsewhere light
sorceries like repair which we just
mentioned hail from the lost land of
oolacile which must have existed when
the ring city was still in its prime
because the two cities are connected by
two characters who appeared who have
moved from one to the other two
characters half light and Manas let's
talk about half light a missionary is
someone who is sent on a religious
mission and half White was one such
missionary sent from an ancient land of
sorcery which was obviously all the sea
but he elected to stay behind in the
ring city becoming the last recorded
spear of the church so this must have
been before the two cities encountered
hardship and the two cities when we
visit them anyway definitely are overrun
as for the second character linking the
two places together I want to convince
you that Manas is at least a pygmy and
potentially even the furtive pygmy may
be from the ring city the locust says
this one met the dark with learning but
in the end learned his knowledge was
wanting the world began without
knowledge or without knowledge Twi'lek
em and according to the white birch
bowed ascription before its description
was changed in a patch it used to read
the bow is a relic from the land of an
old sorcerer who was swallowed by the
abyss and known for his role in the
heroic tale of the abyss walker' the
only possible character known for his
role in the tale of the abyss walker'
who could possibly be an old sorcerer
his Manus which lines up with the fact
that his weapon is indeed a catalyst
thus Manus who is called primeval man by
calf is three things at once Manus is he
who met the dark with knowledge when the
world began Manus is an old sorcerer who
was swallowed by the abyss and Manus
most importantly his primeval man also
known as a pygmy Lord there's a story
here but we can only imagine it it's a
story of how a pygmy Lord left the Ring
City and settled in all the seal and
eventually spread his abyss
[Music]
I'm going to quickfire a few other
curiosities that I've found and you can
follow these up in the description first
woodless may actually be a pygmy in the
literal sense this may well be something
that the japanese community has known
for a long time because the line I may
be small but I will die a colossus more
literally translates to in Japanese even
this
pygmy here was honored to become a lord
this raises interesting implications
when you consider that loot left was
exiled for the forbidden art of soul
transposition and consider also that
Fillion ores vagrant like shell clearly
contains a transposing kill in the
design works concept art so could the
Ring City in fact be Courland
and was wood left exiled from there
reddit user Westby has a great little
thread that goes into more detail and in
a point raised by machi who's one of our
new resident translators Bloodless being
a pygmy around since the very dawn of
the world certainly explains how he
would have knowledge of the first fire
key book whoever she might have been
because the eyes that we find in the
untended graves are the eyes of the
first fire keeper and would let has
dialogue about them saying that they
reveal a frightful betrayal and that
they reveal a light that was lost by all
fire keepers to come after this fire
keeper I've read that some have put
forward that Fillion or was the first
fire keeper and I can say that she is
blind
she's presumably missing eyes and like a
fire keeper she hold the darkness within
her because darkness seeps from where
her eye should be and if look left is
indeed from here then he should know of
home so that lines up pretty well but
all that said I'm not completely
convinced about that I mean the eyes are
found on the corpse of another fire
keeper and while I supposed that they
could be passed down from Fillion or
should fili noise eyes really reveal
such a generic and
of the fire the world we see in billion
or future is more of an end of the world
not just the end of light so as you
might have gathered souls may well be
over but we're not done here
also before I go I am probably going to
be in Japan by the time you see this
video which is amazing so I'm actually
going to do a little travel blog or at
least try to about everywhere bin or the
food I've eaten and all that sort of
thing so if you're interested into more
of a window into my life which I know is
pretty sparse on this channel then I'm
just going to do this for patrons so if
you want to consider becoming one of
them you'll be doing that on behalf of
everyone who watches my videos and you
get to see a little bit of I'm going to
be doing in Japan if that's interesting
to you it'll give me something to do
while the other side of my mind is like
crying that I'm not making videos and
yeah I kind of need to be creating
something to make that anxiety go away
but thank you regardless thank you for
watching and thank you for being the 1%
listening at the end of the video and
I'll see you next time
[Music]